[Music]
the UK is already feeling the effects of
climate change may have been an
afterthought at the last election but
not anymore
this must be the climate election the
future won't get another chance a new
industrial revolution a green industrial
revolution now there are protests in the
street and real political friction over
what to do you can have targets till the
cows come home we're doing an enormous
amount but we need to clearly to do more
so are the parties being straightforward
about their plans we are going to have
to spend this money as a country the
question is not that should we spend it
the question is when and are the British
people ready to go green we have to
create an urgency are there prepared
I hope so we need to get it right
[Music]
the road to Fish Lake Doncaster we're
just a few weeks ago a month's worth of
rain fell in a day for Psalm it's been a
glimpse of a future shaped by extreme
weather events made worse by global
warming climate change when it happens
in your own backyard when it happens in
your own sleepy village you do sit up
and take more of a notice it hits home
it's very very frightening the thought
of this starting to happen more regular
volunteer Wendy Brown bridge has come to
the same conclusion suppose she could
have said have been a bit complacent my
husband was born in this village and
they always said it never flood not
anymore
their concern reflects a national trend
a sky data survey found that more than
half of people believe climate change
now poses a major threat to the UK as
unusual as it may sound in the current
political era the issue of tackling
climate change which means getting to
net zero carbon emissions in the coming
decades it's one of the things that all
the main parties actually agree on but
there the consensus ends there are huge
differences on how to do that how far
and how fast to go and how much money
it's going to take it's the realization
that what's going on in Venice and
Australia and the Arctic fires that's
going on the north of England these are
extreme weather events this is climate
breakdown this is what it looks like the
party with the most uncompromising views
on what to do rather unsurprisingly
is the Green Party Jonathan Bartley
wants to get to net zero carbon
emissions by 2030 20 years before the
government's own target the UK needs to
transform it needs to completely
transform we need to decarbonize every
sector of the economy agriculture
industry energy transport and how much
money is that going to cost we've said
our green New Deal we've been very
upfront about it will cost 91 billion a
year in terms of borrowing and another 9
billion for the running costs in through
increasing corporation tax from 18% to
24% that is a massive increase in
government borrowing it is very
significant increase in government
borrowing but we know that the climate
emergency in climate breakdown will cost
us far more in the long run we are going
to have to spend this money as a country
the question is not should we spend it
the question is when others say it's
irresponsible and will plunge this
country into irrecoverable debt what do
you say to those accusations
I'd say where's the hope at the end of
the second world war we were more in
debt as a country as a proportion
GDP than we are today yet we set up the
NHS we set up the welfare state we
established a new social contract with
people we revolutionized the way our
country lived we can do the same thing
today there is a perception that
actually it's easy for you to promise
these things because the reality is
you're never going to be in power is
that true
time and time and time again we've set
the agenda we've been on the right side
of history where Greens lead others have
followed and I believe on this they will
also have to follow there is no choice
[Music]
labour is promising a similar radical
big-spending approach a green industrial
revolution targeting energy production
jobs transport and more labour seems to
be promising an awful lot here massive
investment hundreds of thousands of new
well-paid jobs billions in economic
benefits and no one left behind it's
wishful thinking that you can deliver
all of that isn't it it's not wishful
thinking because we've got the credible
plans to back it all if we don't take
this action not only will we be heading
towards climate catastrophe but we'll
have missed the biggest opportunity we
have seen in generations to transform
our economy and usher in the next
industrial revolution the revolution
includes an ambitious plan to retrofit
nearly every UK home with energy-saving
measures like insulation better windows
and heating systems labour hopes grants
and interest-free loans will help
talking about upgrading 27 million her
yes over 10 years rough maths is that
you have to do 7,000 homes a day
approximately that's the rate at which
you have to upgrade homes every day for
the next ten that's right but that will
if you take a phased approach to it and
you concentrate predominantly at the
start to those homes that are in the
most need whilst you're building up your
skills base while you're allowing
businesses to invest how are you going
to convince homeowners and households to
get all of this done well certainly what
I'd say is we're not going to force any
homeowner to have changes made to their
home
they don't want to it's all their own
personal choice what we think that by
explaining the scheme to them showing
them that their energy bills are going
to come down that it would be a
no-brainer
this seems optimistic we did the work in
2014
it took about one summer Rob Jones has
already added installation triple
glazing even solar panels it has his
doubts about this happening everywhere
this kind of national program hasn't
really been seen since maybe the war I
don't think any of the parties are
necessarily particularly serious about
how this is going to be accomplished
I can't underestimate the amount of work
that took place in this house
replicating that for tens of millions of
households across Britain is a serious
task I'm not sure many of the parties
are very honest with the public about
about the impact of that or about the
fact that there isn't much of a choice
arguably but there are other issues at
play than just practicality in the
northwest for example the attitude to
going green is not a straightforward one
Manchester's mills and factories put
this region at the center of the
industrial revolution which helped
kickstart global warming and it's voters
have plenty to say about potentially
being on the cusp of another great
change whatever the rival parties say
voters know that transformation on this
scale means sacrifice
we're in a position where money seems to
be needed in every area of our country
NHS education you name it we need money
in the to be invested in the
infrastructure but I guess it's
something that we seriously have to
think about because without a world to
live in safely and you know what future
have we got anyway the next challenge is
grasping what that future might mean
especially for those already struggling
to get ahead
is there any party that you would
consider voting for on the basis of
their climate policies
yeah labour do you worry that as a
steelworker
which is obviously quite carbon
intensive if we have a green industrial
revolution you might be left behind
[Music]
maybe there are others there's a
lingering sense that tackling climate
change is an unfair attack on a precious
heritage without manchester in the 1860
and 1870s
would the world be where it is now why
should we be punished as our little
nation fuel our cars for what's
happening now in the world when you've
got the likes of china and russia and
they come to our country say oh you
can't have a light bulb on for more than
seven minutes because it's blue in there
there are signs that climate change may
emerge as a new political fault line in
this country 58% of those who voted
labour at the last election said it
mattered a great deal that the party
they support makes tackling the issue a
priority nearly double the number who
voted conservative and of those who
wanted to remain in europe it was over
half who felt the same way versus just
over a quarter of leaf voters for the
conservatives who are running on a
brexit platform this means navigating
fraught territory isn't the reality that
your party has made this election about
brexit and therefore it cannot really
afford to fully concentrate and deliver
on climate change pledges I think it's
the opposite I think the only way we're
going to get government focused properly
or Parliament focused properly on this
Jagan
antek challenge of the environment and
climate is by getting grexit done
otherwise we're going to have a
continued state of paralysis the Prime
Minister has declared vote blue go green
on a number of occasions but when you
dig into it the criticism is the party's
record just doesn't stand up to that
there's been a moratorium but not a ban
on fracking you frozen fuel duty you've
banned onshore wind you've ended
subsidies for solar panels there's been
plenty of spending on new road building
just let me finish this there's going to
be a third runway at Heathrow so isn't
it the case that actually when it comes
to tackling climate change your party is
all talking their action I won't pretend
that any government anywhere in the
world is doing enough at the scale of
the challenge I mean if the science is
right and I believe it is then we face
an emergency and I don't think the
collective response of governments
around the world including ours has been
enough and I would never pretend it is I
think we need to continuously do more
the other parties are already promising
to do so all of them suggesting they can
go further and faster are you being out
greened I think from the government's
point of view 2050 is the right target I
actually think we could get there sooner
but I don't think we should legislate
for it to happen sooner but we just
don't know if that's possible
like the Conservatives the Lib Dems have
been accused of not being ambitious
enough on climate they are deeply
concerned about bringing people with
them proposing citizens assemblies to
help unless we get individuals on board
with the difficult transition we need to
make and there needs to be a fair
transition we might get backlash like we
have seen with religion and in France
and we absolutely need to avoid that
because that must stop progress other
British people ready to make all the
changes you've been talking about we
have to create that urgency are they're
prepared I hope so we need to get it
right there's no question that we need
to do this and I'm absolutely committed
to make sure that this doesn't end up in
a party political dingdong this is has
to become something that we embrace as
people together or we are finished but
it's too late to take the politics out
of dealing with climate change
now it's on the ballot paper voters face
a defining choice about what happens to
this country in our warming world Hanna
Thomas Peter Sky News